what's the deal with airplane
peanuts Saturday Night Live is one of
the oldest comedy institutions on the
planet what once was thought of as the
standard of sketch comedy everywhere has
without a doubt fallen off over the past
few years sliding into what many
consider to be an all-time low for the
show in their storied 49-year history
but viewership and ratings were able to
bounce back ever so slightly this past
Saturday thanks to this man Nate baratti
look if you're home I'm as shocked as
you are that I'm here so everybody was
super excited to see Nate barazi hosting
Saturday Night Live and Not Just because
Nate is a great comedian at the top of
his game Who clearly deserves this honor
but also because it's the first time in
a while that we got to see a real
authentic comedian hosting SNL with no
hidden agenda booking Comics as the host
is not only a treat for the viewers but
it's also in the show's best interest
overall just take a look at the numbers
over the last four seasons of Saturday
Night Live over this time period the
average average SNL viewership comes out
to 4.24 million people per episode with
a particularly bad episode being around
3 million people and a great episode
being around 5 million last season the
only episode that broke the 5 million
Mark was hosted by Steve Martin and
Martin sh the season before that they
only featured one comedian as a host
with John meany bringing in 4.7 million
viewers but the real kicker comes from
season 46 which started off with Bill
bur Chris Rock and John meany hosting
three of their first four episodes all
bringing in over 4.7 million views but
the real Smoking Gun from this season
that proves SNL performs better when a
comedian is hosting comes from season 46
episode 6 when 9.1 million people tuned
in to see Dave Chappelle here's what I
mean SNL right now you have to tell
people you're on SNL like if you go to
out to dinner with somebody they go what
do you do for a living you have to go
I'm on SNL Rock Farley Sandler never had
to do that what I what I mean is that as
a cultural monolith like it's over the
yeah this the people that are on the
show are no longer Superstars the medium
is over TV is over SNL you you almost
have to look at like um an appearance on
Carson so like if the actor was more
famous than Carson that was just this
massive moment so the actor the
celebrity that's going on SNL has to be
more famous than SNL having funny people
host a live comedy show might sound
pretty obvious but for some reason it's
a strategy that's evaded the executives
at MBC for a long time the most common
sentiment regarding SNL from every
generation used to be the show was at
its best when I was in high school but
it's fallen off since nowadays I'm
pretty sure everyone agrees that this
show stinks out loud regardless of how
old you even are I don't think there's
many comedy fans out there that
genuinely believe this is a quality show
anymore but Saturday Night Live does
still hold some serious weight in the
comedy World they'll always have the
power of Hardcore Nostalgia they're
still getting 4 million viewers every
week and despite the show's recent fall
from Glory being asked to host an
episode is still a major honor for any
comedian especially for a guy like Nate
barazi who is just a standup with no
traditional acting or sketch background
and has nothing to really promote right
now except his own comedy career yeah I
think the monologue is the part that for
a comic is are going to be the most
comfortable cuz you're just going to go
kind of do your standup so I'm very
excited about the monologue uh the
sketches is you know I mean I did some
sketches when I first started comedy
with my buddy but it's like
nowhere near this level so I'll just
kind of trust I always go into it just
kind of like everybody they know what
they're doing they're pretty successful
TV show so you're like I'll just ride
around with you guys and you tell me
what to do and then I'll just you know
figure it out if you think about
Saturday Night Live in terms of a
modern-day podcast their guest list is
all over the place which makes it hard
as a viewer to commit to watching this
show every single week but it also must
be hard for the writers of this show to
operate within this system when one week
you might have a real comedian like like
Nate barazi or John meany on the show
and the very next week you might find
yourself working with someone like lizo
when I was there uh on the writing staff
the greatest feeling was when a standup
would show up because you knew they
would handle their own monologue do you
is that safe to assume that you were
going to write your own monologue yeah
yeah yeah that's the only thing I can do
that's good like I personally did not
tune in to SNL last weekend but by now
I've seen the clips from all the
sketches Nate was a part of as well as
his opening monologue which I found to
be the best part of his whole appearance
let me know what you thought of Nate
aratan as in the comments of this video
and if you saw his sketches live or
after the fact on YouTube guest spots
from last week The Joe Rogan Experience
talked with Graham Hancock two bears one
cave was Bert and John Stamos kill Tony
this week was with Ryan sickler Giannis
papz and Mike feny Matt and Shane secret
podcast did not have a guest aru garbage
had on Trevor Wallace the honeydude
talked with country Wayne Pete Holmes
was the guest on Whiskey Ginger flagrant
did not have a guest taste buds battled
Milky Way versus Twix y talked with Kim
Conan and Sarah wiin Shank Joe doosa was
on first date and we might be drunk
featured Simon Rex Jordan Jensen Ian
fance and Oz Pearlman Mark think of
someone don't think of your wife too
obvious I never
do yeah B sh baby yeah think of someone
if you're having a birthday party and
somebody you invite but you'd want them
to be there got it somebody that you
know what if they were having a birthday
they'd invite you I hope oh a different
person okay okay all right all right I
got it you know what drop this down go
over there write this down write down
this person's name Jordan since you're
out of me grab that note yeah do you
think she knows this person yes don't
look don't look then don't you
definitely know him him saying him
what's your name d hold out your hand
grab it take a little yeah take it all
make sure I'm not cheating let me grab
this had a birthday party would they
invite you yeah I think so I think so
too you know what you just thought of it
watch his face October November December
January February March April May June
July look at that expression right there
do you see that bam you know what you do
when you think of who you're gonna
invite to your birthday you got to go
Tit for Tat did they invite me the
person you just thought of what month is
he born in oh God April April that's
what I thought wow The Mentalist what
the is happening man I gave it away
I got no Poker Face how' you give it and
you know what I think it's a friend of
the podcast I know who it is it's Gary
Veer isn't it wow how the hell did you
do that what open up the wall scared
open up the wall if it's a photo of Gary
I'm kidding uh don't take my credit card
what the hell is she doing woman this
around wait no no no zip open up oh my
Lord if you got a picture of Gary in
there I'm calling the Poli picture of
Gary and there should be a a zipper and
read the note on the back to Mark what
the wish Gary happy birthday for me
oh my god dude what the is this man
all right I don't know how he did that
what the what kind of sorcery
are you ping bro down on anything do me
am I or am I not a gay
man we can all answer that one we don't
need a mentalist does even count if
you're on Molly I don't think it does
the Tim Dylan show did not have a guest
Angela White and Lou Kats were both on
tiger belly the block podcast had on
Sarah Silverman Mike Cannon and Mike
feno were on hey babe Usama sadik went
on Chrissy chaos Tim High Decker was the
guest on take your shoes off Being Ian
with Jordan welcomed Kyle dunigan Conor
o Ali visited stav's World Jamie Kennedy
took a ride on the Harland Highway and
Mike feni on both you know what dude and
only fans before we hear about the new
comedy specials from this week here's a
quick word from the sponsor of today's
video my bookie right now is the best
time of year when it comes to sports and
my bookie is the easiest way to get in
on the fun especially when you take
advantage of their 100% firsttime
deposit bonus which basically means when
you use our promo code JK wrld D
whatever amount of money you put into
bet with the first time my bookie will
give you the same amount for free my
bookie also has a really easy cash out
system odd boosting crypto payments and
the ability to watch live games on their
website while you bet my favorite play
this weekend is under 49 in the bills
Bangals game but let me hear your
favorite picks in the comments below
again you can use promo code JK wrld to
claim your 100% cash deposit bonus when
you use the link in our description now
back to the video as far as new standup
specials are either out right now or
coming out soon Ralph Barbosa cowabanga
premiered on Netflix today and when
asked about the name Ralph had to say I
named it cabanga cuz that's a cool ass
word Pete Holmes I'm not for everyone
premiered last week on Netflix as well
as Noel Miller's first hour special
titled stop crying and Mike FY a night
at the comedy seller and a few specials
in the works that will be coming out
soon Trevor Wallace is set to release
his debut stum special on Prime video
November 14th titled pterodactyl which
comes only one day before Matt R's debut
Netflix special natural selection also
not technically a standup special but
another comedy project coming out soon
civic duty a short film by San ruof
starring Joe list and Tommy Pope will be
premiering ing November 9th at the New
York Comedy Festival other than that the
best of October video is going to be
coming out very soon which will include
all of your favorite podcast funniest
moments from last month all put together
in one video that you can find right
here only on joke world so hit subscribe
right now thank you so much for watching
and happy
Halloween at joke
world that's did it joke
world and the world is
wld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke World check it out